GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
HEAR THE FIRST AND HAVE COME ON
ARTS AND TO SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA BEFORE WE
STARTED HERE. THERE ARE A FEW
HOUSE ITEMS HOW LIKE TO COVER
FIRST I'LL LIKE TO THANK THE
STAFF WHO HAVE OR- THE- TO
CONDUCT BUSINESS OF LEGISLATURE
POSSIBLE DUE TO THE CURRENT
SAVE AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
PARTICIPATING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
AND THIS HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGH ALL THE STATE CAPITOL
BEAUTY WE HAVE LIMIT THE FIFTH
WHEEL SPACES IN THIS ROOM FOR.
TO WATCH PARTICIPATE IN
PRACTICE PHYSICAL DISTANCES SO
WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS
FOR WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY
FOR THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM TO
DO. ROOM THIRTY SEVEN WE ARE
CONDUCTING A PHYSICAL DISTANCE
IN PERSON HEARING. IN THIS
SPACE WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE
SEVEN MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTAIN
JUNE AND OF STAFF AND THE
LIMóN NUMBER OFF THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAXIMIZE
SIX FEET OF SPACING MAINTAIN.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCE BUT A PROPOSAL CALLS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL M. FOR THOSE
HERE TODAY IN THE HEARING. YOU
ANYONE MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH A MICROPHONE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. AS TO YOU
PLEASE. DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU HAVE DONE
TESTIFYING OR- YOU RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE REFER TO OUR
SERVER THIS CALL TERMS. LEAVE
THE CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR THE DIAL AND
WITNESS. WE WILL ALSO BE USING
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICES
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESSES CAN
TESTIFY ON THE BILL THE CALLING
NUMBER FOUR DOES HEARING IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE OR WEBSITE
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN.
IF YOU ARE CALLING AIM PLEASE
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU ARE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE PLACE
IN THE QUEUE BASED ON WHETHER
YOU'LL SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING HIM
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISES. THIS INCLUDE AMUSING
YORK- LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR OF SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
TO SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
A MAIN WITNESSES PROVIDING
TESTS OF TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST AVAIL. YOU'LL WILL
REMAIN ON A LIFELINE AND TO-
WERE NOT WILL NEED TO MUTE YOUR
SELF AND TO YOU OUR CALL ON TO
SPEAK. IF YOU ARE HAVING ANY
PROBLEM WITH THE MODERATE THE
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMEY HE OUT AND I. ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE THREE FOUR FIVE
ZERO. AM I STAFF WILL BE THERE
TO TRY TO HELP YOU. I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THIS
POSITION THAT HAVE A POTENT
PORTAL. COMMITTEE WEBSITE THANK
YOU FOR BEING AN WAS CLOSE AS
WE EMPLOYMENT AT NEW MASTER TO
CONTINUE SERVICE IF YOU CALL IT
FOR. WHAT THE ALSO BE PAYING
FOR AT RISK FOR OF THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERN THAT WE ARE
USING. IS NOW TIME TO CALL THE
MEETING. TO ORDER IN. WHAT ARE
THE- MESSAGE MATHIS WILL FOR A
FILLING IN DR CHOI WHO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF MASS. WHO
AND WHY WHAT THE SECRETARY
PLEASE HE ROLL. YOUR THANK YOU
FOR YEAH HERE HERE DAVID. YEAH
YOU HEAR YEAH. KAMLAGER ALIVE
IF HELLO EVERYONE FOR THAT.
RATHER NUMBER PRESS DIFFERENT.
HERE THERE IS HERE WELL THANK
VERY MUCH WOULD HAVE QUORUM IN
A WILL MOVE TO THE COMES KELLER
WILL HAVE THREE ON THE COUNCIL
READ OF THE- FOR. ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB IS NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
THE DESK CHAIR HAS A TO PASS
THE RECOMMENDATION THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE. AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED SORRY. CREATION
YOURSELF I'M SORRY YES TO PASS
TO DO A COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AND THE- THE
SECOND OF FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TWENTY THREE HUNDRED
THIS ALSO HAS THE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWENTY FOUR TEN IS TO
PASS TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
PHIL WILL HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ASKED DAMON DOWN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE SEC CALENDAR OF PAUL
PASSENGERS I. HI HI YOUR TIME
IF YOU. BY. ALL RIGHT I IS
THERE ANYTHING HIGH YEAH. OKAY
ALL RIGHT GREAT WERE ALL THE
MEMBERS ARE. RIGHT GREAT OKAY
NOW MOVES ON TO THE PRESENT OF
A THE ONLY ONE. AS A READ FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT AM I GOING TO. AS
THE- RIGHT WITH. SURE. SURE OF
BUT I NEED TO LOOK AT. FOR THIS.
OKAY. ONE SECOND IT'S BEEN A
MOTION WITH THE BILL AND A
SECOND MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR
PRESENTATION THANK YOU BYE SURE
AND MEMBERS ALL MAKE IT SHORT
THIS- TODAY TO PROCESS AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WHO
WATCHES THE OF BAIL TO PROTECT
CHILDREN IN THE PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS BY CREATING CLEAR
GUIDELINES FOR THEIR AGENTS
THAT ALIGN WITH THE EXISTING-
PROTECTION FOR MINORS IN
ENTERTAINMENT. THIS ROOM NO
THAT WE PASS SB TWO ZERO SIX
LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA YOUNG
ATHLETE CAN NOW AND WILL PROFIT
FROM THEIR NAME IMAGE OR
LIKENESS AND STILL PLAY NC
DOUBLE A GOVERNMENTS TO SUPPORT
THOSE ENDORSEMENT CONTRACT WILL
REQUIRE THE AID OFFERS SAVVY
SPORTS AGENT INCOMPETENT IN
ADDITION CALIFORNIA MAY. I MAY
OUT THAT MAY MAYES AFFLECK WHO
HAVE REACHED THE PROFESSIONAL
RANK AS THE MINERS. AS ONE
RECENT EXAMPLE IS YA ALL THE
VIA- MUTRIE WHO IS THIRTEEN
YEARS OLD AND ALREADY THE HOUSE
AND I KEY CONTRACT. SADLY WHILE
WE ARE CELEBRATING THE SUCCESS
OF OUR YOUNG ATHLETES RECENT
EVENT HAS BROUGHT TO LIGHT TO
THE FACT THAT SEXUAL ABUSE
HARASSMENT AND THE MISTREATMENT
OF AFFLECK IS SHOCKINGLY COMMON.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT CHILD-
ATHLETES ARE JEFF BASS DRIVEN
TO REACH THEIR GOAL. AS CHILD
PERFORMERS. AND WE- ARE EQUALLY
VULNERABLE TO THOSE WHO WOULD
TRADE ON THEM. AND THEIR- THEIR
PROTECTION UNDER LAW SHOULD BE
EQUAL TO. THIS BILL USE AN
EXISTING AND SUCCESSFUL
FRAMEWORK AND THE LAW OF
REGULATION OF TALENT AGENTS. TO
APPLY TO SPORTS AGENT AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WILL PROVIDE
THAT NO ATHLETE GAUGER MAY
ENTER INTO A CONTRACT OR SEND
THE MINOR TO ANY LOCATION WHICH
WOULD BE HALF. OR DETRIMENTAL
TO THE HEALTH SAFETY MORAL OR
EDUCATION OF THE MONTH OF THE
MIKE BINDER I HAVE A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE AVAIL AND I'D
BEACH IS IT'S ON THE PHONE OR
HIS OF OPPRESSING HERE ON THE
PHONE OKAY CAN THE MODERATOR
PLEASE CONTACT. ANDREA J. INTO
THE RING. MODERATOR WE ARE
READY FOR ANDREA JAEGER ARE
WITH US FOR AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT. YEAH YOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO WE CAN HEAR
YOU. HELLO THANK YOU- FIRST OF
ALL I WANTED- THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR COMING TOGETHER IT'S
CERTAINLY A DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT WORLD RIGHT NOW AND
FOR ALL OF YOU TO COME TOGETHER
FOR THE PROTECTION OF MINORS IN
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS IS- IT'S
JUST. ON BEHALF OF ALL MY YEARS
OF PROFESSIONAL SPORTS I THANK
YOU FOR THAT. AND I'M I'M VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT. AB TWO FIVE
EIGHT BECAUSE I A WITH A
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE AT THE AGE
OF FOURTEEN THAT WAS NUMBER TWO
IN THE WORLD AT AGE. SIXTEEN
AND I'M- IT THERE'S SO MUCH
THAT GOES ON THAT PEOPLE ARE
REAL EXCITED ABOUT SEEING. YOU
IN PROFESSIONAL SPORTS HISTORY
THE ANSWER. TO STADIUM SEATS.
ON TO THE TELEVISION SCREENS
THAT INCREASES. ALL KINDS OF
EXPOSURE FOR THE SPORT BUT
WHATEVER THAT MINOR TO BACK.
THEN BUT IN THAT SAME AREA OF
EXCITEMENT WE NEED TO BE
PROTECTING THE OWNERS. THERE'S
JUST. THERE IS A PROTECTION OUT
THERE FOR. A PROFESSIONAL WITH.
BE IN CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU IT IS
ARE DOING A COULD FRIED COME.
AND IT GOING TO DURING THE ON
AND I'M A MINOR AND- THE WHAT
YOU ACCOMPLISHING. FOR THE GOOD.
FOR THE ENTERTAINERS THAT WERE
THERE I HAD TO ABIDE BY THOSE
RULES BECAUSE NOW I HAD A- LIKE
ONE OF THOSE DOCTOR CARDS
BECAUSE I WAS IN A COMMERCIAL.
THEY HAD TO MAKE SURE MY PARENT
WAS THERE THEY HAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT MY PARENT WITHIN EITHER
STRIKE YOUR VOICE THEY HAD TO
MAKE SURE. EDUCATION THE MORAL.
SO MANY DIFFERENT DOT. AND I
WISH SO. FOR THAT. BUT YET THE
OF MY PROFESSIONAL WHATEVER I
DID THAT WAS NEVER THERE. IT
WAS NEVER THAT PROTECTION CHAU
FOR YOU TO THINK. THAT YOU NEED
TO TAKE WHAT YOU ALREADY HAVE
IN PLACE. FOR THE ENTERTAINMENT
FOR THE MINERS TO BEAR TO
PROTECT THEM. IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. THESE KIDS ARE
COMING IN AND AS GOOD AS THEY
ARE IN THEIR PROFESSIONAL
SPORT. EVEN BEATING TEARS THAT
ARE ADULTS. AND SUCCEEDING IN
MAKING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
THEY'RE GETTING ABUSED BODIES
AND DAMAGE MARK THERE'S FINANCE.
THERE'S BOB. ON THE PERSON
MENTIONED THE- JIM SO IF YOU
COULD LOOK AT THIS FOUND IT
DRAWN UP PRETTY BRILLIANTLY BY
DANA AND- I'M EXCITED TO
PARTICIPATE AND THAT'S BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN OVER FORTY YEARS THAT
I'VE BEEN A PROFESSIONAL SPORTS
OF THE MINOR AND THERE STILL IS
NO PROTECTION THERE'S NO SAFETY
MEASURES TO HELP. THAT WOULD
LOOK AT THE HEALTH THE SAFETY
THE MORALS EDUCATION THE
CHARACTER AGAIN BUYER BENCH OF
WHERE. MINOR PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES ARE PLAYING THAT
NOBODY PROTECTING THEM TO
SAFETY JUST BEEN IGNORED WE'VE
BEEN MIRED THEIR TALENT BUT
IT'S BEEN AT A COST OF THEIRS
IF THE AND SO I I'M- HERE
THERE'S QUESTION. AND I. YOUR
TO THE BOARD EXCITED AS X. TO
PAY THE BECAUSE- IT WILL. IT
REALLY TO REFER FOR MINE THEY
WERE ACTUALLY. BE ABLE TO OUT
AND TRAIN AND COMPETE. IN
KNOWING THAT THERE'S A SAFETY
MEASURE OUT THERE FOR THEM AND
NOT HAVE LIVES ROOM. BECAUSE
JUST BECAUSE OF THEIR AGE AND
THAT THERE'S NO PROTECTION AND
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF THEM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENCE THIS CALL. ARE YOU
FINISHED WITH A PRESENTATION.
YES I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT JUST
BOTH THE STATE HELLO OR IF I
WAS SUPPOSED TO TALK SO I HOPE
IT WAS OKAY FOR ME TO TALK AT
THAT PARTICULAR TIME YES NO WAS
PERFECT AND I'M GONNA ASK-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM. THE A YEAR
BEFORE SHE HANGS UP. OKAY SEEN
NUMBERS EAGER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. WE WILL NOW
PROCEED TO WITNESSES ARE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. SEEN NONE OF IT
TO THE MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ON THE
TELEPHONE. AT THIS TIME IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NOTING HERE AT THIS TIME.
OKAY LET ME ASK MR MODERATOR
DOING ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT ON THE
TELEPHONE. AND AT THIS TIME IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. OKAY GOING
ONCE GOING TWICE. RIGHT AT THIS
TIME- BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE TO THE AUTHOR. YEAH I
GUESS I DO- I'M JUST CURIOUS SO
MINOR HERE BEING UNDER THE AGE
OF EIGHTEEN. SO A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD WHO'S- GOING TO GO TO
A SPORTS CONVENTION IN A
CONVENTION CENTER TO SIGN
AUTOGRAPHS TO THE TABLE LET'S
SAY OR TO MAKE AN APPEARANCE
BUT MOST OF THOSE VENUES THEY
SELL ALCOHOL SOMEWHERE ON
PREMISES SO THAT WOULD APPLY TO
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE A
GUARD OR SOMEBODY WITH EVEN AT
THAT AGE RESUMING. OKAY I'M I
MEAN IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S
PROBABLY NOT THAT DIFFICULT
FOR. NOW FOR THESE MINERS TO
HAVE. A AN ADULT WITH THEM- BUT
IT DOES SEEM I MEAN WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT LET'S SAY THAT.
SOMEHOW THAT ANOTHER WAS
ALCOHOL SOLD THIS SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD DRIVES HIMSELF THERE
DOES THIS THAT SOMEONE THAT I
TRY TO GO CRIMINALLY PROSECUTE-
THE MANAGER OF THE BOOKING
AGENT FOR THAT. ROLE WOULD PUT
THIS BILL PRETTY MUCH WHICH IN
LINE WAS FOR WERE DOING WAS
STATED A YOUNG ENTERTAINER. SO
THERE REALLY- TO PRETTY MUCH
FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES THIS YOUR
THAT THIS IN EUROPE THAT YOU.
MENTION IT DOES HAPPEN YOU KNOW
TODAY WAS THE A YOUNG
ENTERTAINER. AND THIS ONE JUST
APPLY THE SAME TO THE YOUNG
ATHLETES. OKAY. DEVELOPMENTS
FROM THE NO I DID I UNDERSTAND
THAT IT DOESN'T APPLY IF THE
BOOK THERE- IF THEY DO THEIR
OWN BOOKING RIGHT SO IF THE
YOUNG PERSON DOES THERE ARE
MAKES THEIR OWN ARRANGEMENTS
THAT IT DOESN'T APPLY- SO THIS
IS REALLY AIMED AT THOSE THAT
ARE AT THE STATURE OF HAVING A
PROFESSIONAL MAN DOING THE
BOOKINGS WHICH GIVES ME THAT
ACTUALLY MAKES ME FEEL BETTER
ABOUT IT BECAUSE I THINK.
ATHLETES WHO MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED PROFESSIONAL BUT
ARE. A PROFESSIONAL SURFER OR-
YOU KNOW WHERE THEY- MAY NOT
HAPPEN THE MANAGER. THAT YOU
KNOW YOU WOULDN'T WANT THEIR
PARENTS TO BE PROSECUTED
BECAUSE A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD OR
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD. THEMSELVES
GOES TO SOME. WEEKEND
CONFERENCE WHERE THEY MIGHT BE
ALCOHOL SO THIS DOESN'T APPLY
TO THOSE KINDS OF SCENARIOS
RIGHT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT HIM
MANAGE YOUR BOOKING THEM. INTO
A SITUATION YOU'RE RIGHT RIGHT
OKAY THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. WITHOUT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS ANNA ANY FINAL
COMMENTS BY THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN THIS BILL
WILL PROTECT THE CHILDREN IN
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS AND GIVE
NEEDED GUIDANCE TO DOES AGENT
WHO REQUIRE- GROUP
REPRESENTATIVE SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOOK. RIGHT THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION WITH THE BILL THERE'S
BEEN A SECOND ABOUT A SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. KANSEN CHU
HI. KANSEN CHU ÁI DEEP.
DAVID CHIU HI DAVID CHIU AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
GALLAGHER. HELLO I MATHIS BY
MATHIS AYE NAZARIAN. IS THERE
IN ALL RIGHT THE MOTION HAS SIX
VOTES AND THE BILL IS OUT-
SHOULD LIKE TO PLACE IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATRUS
SO BUT- WE ARE WAITING FOR
RESEARCH THE VOICE HEARD BACK
SO WE THOUGHT. ARE OKAY SO YOUR
BILL IS OUT AND A WITHOUT I
THINK THAT IS THE END OF THE
GENDER UNLESS WE'RE GONNA WAIT
FOR ANY UPS MEMBERS IT'S TIME
NOT. MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE A MEETING. OKAY
THE OTHER TWO CLOSE IS A
MEETING THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE REMOTE. THANK YOU EVERYBODY
THANK YOU. I GOT MORE THAN
LIKELY MORE. I THE WOMAN
PROJECT YEAH BUT REGULATION ON
THE RIGHT NOT. YEAH. GALLAGHER
THAT LITTLE. LOTS OF LEGO.